So focusing on details first is a really common
problem in design and in development because when you do
this you can really only optimize locally. So what's a
good solution for this problem? Well in design we have
a technique it's called wireframing or low res wireframing. It
helps us really focus on the UX first and the
big picture. Without getting caught in the UI details too
soon. I know in development, they do something very similar?
>> Yeah, I know.
>> In development there's a really easy trap to fall into,
is when you start coding, you you just want to create functions.
>> And you don't want to think about
abstraction and you don't want to think about encapsulation.
>> So as a Java developer maybe you make the static class and you
have a lot of methods in it
and you forget about interfaces and classes altogether.
>> That's again an example of in development,
where when you focus on the details kind
of bad things happen. So it's kind of
always a good idea in development and design
to think about the big picture first. So the sign in and
the check out example we just gave you, imagine that is part
of an experience of a cookie buying application. So here's how you
really get started, imagine there's a task that your user wants to
complete. So for this example, it's I'm hungry for cookies I want to
get some and eat the cookies, basically. So then you think about
what steps does your user need to go through to complete this
task? So this is an easy example cause we only have one task.
So the steps would be, sign in decide which cookie you
want, pay for your cookies and then eat the cookies. So when
we write out each of these steps at a high level like
this, each of these steps is kind of like a Java interface.
>> Exactly when you think about a Java interface, it's
something that doesn't have any implementation, so you're not really
thinking about the low level details but you're thinking about
the contract that interface has with other interfaces and classes.
>> Which in this case
if you look at the steps, it's how these steps connect with each other.
>> So instead of focusing just on one step and nothing else,
you're really thinking about the big picture. Exactly, so now that we're
thinking about the sign in experience as part of our overall flow
in order to buy cookies, how do you think we should start?
>> Do we even need a sign in experience? You know actually, we
might not actually need a Sign In experience. We could have an anonymous
experience because what if I just want to install the
app and just get cookies. And maybe after I've used the
application or maybe even gotten some cookies for the first
time, I might think, okay maybe I'll use this application again.
>> That's a good point but actually the way I would use
this application is that I actually do want to sign in because
I want to see my order history any my payment history. And
actually I want to place orders that I've already placed before. Okay.
>> So for me, like for someone like me, if I was a user, I would actually
want the sign in experience sooner rather than
later. So we could actually give the user
an option of just getting straight into the
app and buying cookies and just skipping sign in.
>> Right. Or for users that are more
like you, we could let them sign in initially.
>> Yeah that's true, so actually what we could do is, instead
of having this sign in happen up front maybe we can actually.
>> Allow them to flow through this application without signing in but when they
actually need to then block them with the sign in. Just before check out.
>> I like that,
that would actually end up in a much nicer flow. Yeah.
>> This is great I hadn't even thought about
it but now that if we actually move the
sign in to this step it actually ends up
in a much better application. I agree, I think
that using low res wire framing really helped us
elevate the whole discussion. We could look at the
sign in experience and really see how it made
the most sense to put in the application over all.
>> Exactly.
>> Which again it results in a much better application
for the end user. Yep.
>> So, we haven't really changed anything.
>> We've just thought about it at a high level and optimized how they
link up just like good interfaces should
and we can worry about the implementation later.
>> I think, this deserves a fist bump. Low res framing wire for the win.
>> Boom.